-Finally, guys, I know a lot
of people find math boring.
Well, that's why we've updated
math to make the equations
about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics".
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Yes!
Let's take a look
at our first equation here.
If you take "M3GAN" plus
physical fitness,
it equals Meghan Trainor.
You see what I'm saying?
-Ah.
-Meghan Trainor.
-Meghan Trainor, yeah.
-You get the idea.
-Trainor.
-Here's another one.
T.J. Maxx plus a sale equals
"Everything Everywhere
All at Once".
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you take the Kool-Aid Man
plus Sam Elliott,
it equals the Chiefs'
head coach, Andy Reid.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I see it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Here's another one.
You arm plus cutting an avocado
minus paying attention
equals Thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you take Caesar...
-Yep.
-...plus six shots of tequila,
it equals SZA.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hail SZA.
Here's another one.
"Dumb and Dumber" minus dumb
plus a Boston accent
equals "Dahmer".
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Popular.
-If you take Daniel Day-Lewis...
-Mm-hmm.
-...times two plus Sandra Oh,
it equals...
[ Singing ] ♪ Day-o, day-o ♪
[ Applause ]
Here's another one --
a Tesla plus a low battery
minus a charging station
for 100 miles equals,
"Welp, this is
where I live now."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's what I mean.
And finally, if you take
"The Bachelor"
plus 10 years,
it equals "MILF Manor".
There you go.
-Oh!
-That's all the time we have
for "Popular Mathematics".